franchi une nouvelle étape avec le vote
en commission à l'Assemblée nationale il
avait été on le rappelle largement durci
ici au Sénat par la majorité de la
droite et du centre et une grande partie
de modifications du Sénat ont été
effacées par les députés voilà ce texte
avance sur une ligne de crête politique
depuis le début d'ailleurs de sa
présentation il y a plus d'un an
maintenant la droite a fixé plusieurs
lignes rouges largement réécrit le texte
avec l'ajout de dizaines d'articles
quand il éta examiné en novembre ici à
la Chambre haute la majorité
présidentielle veut un autre équilibre
et donc a voté cet autre équilibre la
semaine dernière en commission on va
donc probablement Orian vers une impasse
entre les deux chambres du Parlement
avec deux visions différentes de
l'équilibre de ce projet de loi
immigration alors concrètement qu'est-ce
qu'on fait les députés qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont effacé comme modification du Sénat
alors par exemple on va prendre un
exemple très symbolique très important
l'aide médicale d'État on voit là
vraiment la clé du désaccord entre les
deux chambres les sénateurs voulaient
remplacer cette aide médicale d'État par
une aide mé ic d'urgence cela a été
gommé en commission à l'Assemblée
nationale les députés ont rétabli l'ame
même sort pour d'autres modifications
auquel tenait la droite et le centre au
Sénat des lit de séjour illégal côat
migratoire durcissement du regroupement
familial ce sont quelques exemples de ce
qui a été rejeté par les députés la
semaine dernière il y a un point du
texte qui fait encore débat c'est le
fameux article 3 sur la régularisation
des travailleurs dans les médetiens en
tension article écrit aussi au Sénat
voilà en enlevant la régularisation de
droit pour ces travailleurs sans papier
dans un nouvel article les sénateurs
avaient écrit que ces régularisations se
feraient au cas par cas par les préfets
les députés ont réétabli une version
plus proche de ce que voulait le
gouvernement en intégrant simplement un
droit de veto pour les préfets le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui à
l'Assemblée nationale a dit avoir trouvé
ce compromis ingénieux je cite Gérald
Darmanin c'était jeudi dernier au moment
de soutenir cette modification des
député écouter le ministre de
l'Intérieur il m'a paraît assez
nécessaire de pouvoir distinguer dans le
texte de loi que nous faisons la fermeté
absolue que nous voulons contre les
étrangers délinquants puisque ce texte
le prévoit ce qui n'avait pas été fait
auparavant et que nous réparons des
erreurs mais aussi la fin d'hypocrisie
parce que je pense que c'est ce que
demande nos concitoyens voilà à la fin
lors du vote dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi cet équilibre n'a convaincu que
les députés de la majorité
présidentielle et ceux du petit groupe
lot vous savez composé d'indépendants et
d'élus et des outremires le texte arrive
donc maintenant en séance lundi lundi 11
11 décembre on verra si l'équilibre
trouvé en commission des lois est adopté
à nouveau en séance dans l'hémicycle et
on va parler de ce texte alorsel Jourda
j'imagine que vous ne vous attendiez pas
à ce que les députés reprennent
intégralement la version du Sénat mais
que pensez-vous généralement de ce qui a
été voté après on va rentrer dans le
détail est-ce que pour vous c'est un
détricotage qui va trop loin alors bien
évidemment c'est un détricotage qui va
trop loin puisque nous avions essayé de
donner une cohérence au texte en fait ce
que la majorité présidentielle appelait
équilibre et pour moi un manque de choix
une absence de choix d'une politique
migratoire puisque d'un côté sans doute
pour faire plaisir à l'aile droite de la
majorité présidentielle on essayait une
certaine fermeté et de l'autre côté
notamment avec l'article 3 c'était la
négation de toute politique migratoire
en laissant une porte ouverte totale par
un droit opposable à la régularisation
donc on ne peut pas se satisfaire d'un
texte qui n'a aucun axe politique en
terme de politique migratoire alors que
c'est précisément nécessaire en ce
moment pour vous il y a pas de cohérence
dans le texte qui est sorti de la
commission il n'y en avait pas eran
balanan vous aviez qualifié vous
provocation le texte qui était sorti du
Sénat oui parce que sous sous la volonté
de de de de plus de fermeté on fait des
choses inefficass et et je pense qu'un
texte de cet enjeu avec les sujets
migratoires qui sont des sujets
importants qui sont des sujets de
société pour notre pays qui sont des
sujets économiques et qui sont des
sujets aussi de justice et et de d'un
certain nombre de nos valeurs d'accueil
dans ce pays je pense qu' il faut pas
être dans l'idée de faire des textes
plus répressifs ou plus
gauche droite il faut faire des tests
qui des textes qui sont justes
humanistes et efficaces et le texte quoi
qu'on dise madame Jourda le texte
initial avait un certain équilibre le le
texte du Sénat a voulu durcir tout un
tas de de sujets il y a des sujets
d'ailleurs sur lesquels le le le les
parlementaires du de l'Assemblée ont
préféré garder des choses et puis
d'autres on a supprimé donc c'est c'est
le jeu parlementaire hein je je suis
désolé c'est aussi normal que la
représentation nationale c'est exime sur
un texte qui est quand même un texte du
enfin un texte important pour les pour
les députés mais en quoi c'était une
provocation parce que c'est fort c'éit
une provocation parce que parce que on
voyait bien qu'il y avait la la la
volonté de pousser le curseur très très
loin bon c'est c'est chacun était dans
son rôle et il est passé au Sénat chez
nous en commission il est passé très
largement 34 voix contre 16 en
commission à 2h40 du matin vendredi donc
les les commissaires aux loi étaient
présents étaient mobilisés et le texte
est passé maintenant on va continuer le
travail et on continuera après le
travail avec des sénateurs de toute
façon Merel Jorda sur ce ce ce terme de
provocation et aprèsan banan je vous
ferai réagir sur le manque de
cohérence alors on peut effectivement si
on est très en désaccord sur la version
du Sénat estimer que c'est provocateur
maintenant moi j'entends mon collègue
qui dit qu'il faut un texte juste humain
tout ça est extraordinaire mais la
politique migratoire elle est la même
pour tous les pays qui sont dotés de
frontière une politique migratoire c'est
dire qui rentre qui reste et à quelles
conditions dans un pays c'est ça ça
n'est que ça on peut estimer que des
conditions doivent être plus
restrictives c'est ce que nous avons
estimé parce que aujourd'hui on rentre
extrêmement facilement en France de
façon légale he plus de 300000 Primo
délivrance l'année dernière ce qui est
un chiffre assez important alors qu'on
voit et pour traiter le budget de
l'immigration on on le voit tous les ans
le problème aujourd'hui c'est le nombre
d'entrées en France on a un nombre
d'entrées si important qu'on narrive
plus à accueillir qu'on arrive plus à
intégrer et qu'on arrive même plus à
appliquer la loi c'est-à-dire que des
gens qui sont en situation irrégulière
sur le territoire qui donc n'obéissent
pas à toutes ces conditions posées par
la politique migratoire reste en France
nous avons des irréguliers que nous ne
pouvons plus expulser nous avons un
nombre assez important de de qtf
obligation de quitter le territoire
français qui sont des décisions
administratives délivrées à des
personnes qui n'ont pas de titre donc
qui ne respectent pas les conditions de
la politique migratoire qui ne sont
exécuté aujourd'hui qu'à 7 % donc nous
voyons bien que le chiffre est un
problème donc il s'agit aussi d'avoir un
droit qu'on applique et d'avoir une
politique migratoire cohérente ce qui
n'était pas le cas avec le texte initial
don Géral hermanant disait que cétait le
plus ferme de ces 20 dernières années
alors on ne doit pas reprendre les
multiples textes des 20 dernières années
il manque un aspect qui a toujours
manqué à mon sens et là-dessus tout le
monde peut battre sa coupe c'est
précisément l'aspect de maîtrise des
entrées nous ne maîtrisons pas les
entrées tant que nous ne maîtrisons pas
les entrées nous ne maîtrisons pas le
reste de la chaîne donc un des aspects
qui a été supprimé par l'Assemblée
nationale mais qui était primordial
c'était tout de même le débat au
Parlement la représentation nationale
qui est l'Assemblée nationale mais aussi
le Sénat le débat au Parlement qui
permettait effectivement de fixer des
quotas dans ce qui était admissible he
c'est-à-dire hors droit d'asile et
regroupement familial et ça c'était
important et le durcissement des
conditions effectivement d'entrer sur le
territoire faisait partie de cetteette
maîtrise de l'immigration donc on a
perdu cet aspect qui aujourd'hui est
primimordial et ne pas le voir nous fait
perdre beaucoup de
temps je avant de parler de quota avant
de parler de politique migratoire je je
pense qu'il y a un sujet qu'il faut
aborder et c'est le sujet que que que
visiblement euh la droite sénatoriale et
la droite la droite à l'Assemblée ne ne
veut pas voir c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait
d'un certain nombre de personnes qui
dans notre pays travaillent cotisent
payent leurs impôts et sont dans des
situations irrégulières alors attention
ils sont dans des situations
irrégulières très peu parce qu'ils ont
fraudé hein euh souvent c'est parce que
problèm administratif euh
parfois comment
dire je a une erreur de de papier parce
qu'ils ont pas fait ce qu'il fallait
parfois une erreur de l'administration
aussi et on a beaucoup de personnes dans
notre pays qui participent à la
production nationale qui participe à la
création de valeur dans notre pays et
qui peuvent pas s'intégrer vous pouvez
pas vous intégrer sérieusement quand
vous travaillez la journée et que la
soirée et et le matin vous pouvez pas
vous occuper de vos enfants les amener à
l'école parce que vous avez peur de de
d'être contrôlé ce n'est pas possible
donc il faut aussi gérer ce sujet alors
c'est l'article 4 bis et et moi c'est
là-dessus que je pense que justement
régularisation voilà et c'est là que
nous avons une cohérence c'est-à-dire la
cohérence de bien accueillir les gens
que nous pouvons accueillir et après je
vous rejoins madame Jourda on ne pourra
pas accueillir tout le monde
effectivement mais attention tout à
l'heure juste avant on parlait des
changements climatiques on le sait
aujourd'hui on va avoir des flux
migratoires nouveaux il va falloir il va
falloir anticiper tout ça et je je pense
que parler de quota parler de politique
chiffré tout ça tout ça oui il faudra
peut-être y réfléchir il faudra même
sûrement y réfléchir sans parler de
quotas à mon avis parce qu'on ne peut
pas mettre des quotas mais on peut avoir
des des orientations mais par contre
traitons gérons ces gens qui sont en
France qui et qui ont la dans leur
immense majorité l'envie de s'intégrer
au pays un mot sur les quotas on va
revenir sur la régularisation mais sur
les quotas eron Banon dit on peut pas
mettre de quotas mais bien sûr que si on
peut mettre des quotas on ne peut pas
effectivement en mettre on ne peut
mettre que des objectifs chiffrés sur
des politiques sur des politiques qui ne
dépend pas que de la France c'est-à-dire
le droit d'asile et le regroupement
familial mais pour toutes les autres
types d'immigration notamment
l'immigration économique on peut
parfaitement mettre des quotas et on
peut parfaitement mettre des quotas avec
des critères de qualification de
l'immigration économique par exemple on
peut parfaitement mettre des quotas sur
les étudiants enfin les quotas ça existe
c'est possible en tout cas et si on ne
l'a pas fait jusqu'à maintenant c'était
sans doute un choix mais ça n'est pas
impossible loin de là ou non mais je je
a ça a été rappelé je trouve très bien
que ça soit rappelé c'est que la
question de l'asile la question du
regroupement familial c'est
conventionnel c'est on ne pourra on ne
pourra pas on pourra pas y
toucher la question des des étudiants je
rappelle que la France accueille
beaucoup d'étudiants que c'est une vraie
force pour notre
pays on peut réfléchir à à des nombre
effectivement qui permettent à nos à nos
universités de l'encaisser c'est c'est
tout à fait logique mais ne parlons pas
de de ne faisons pas de politique du
chiffre faisons une politique d'ambition
pour le pays et c'est ça la la
différence peut-être entre avoir des
objectifs chiffré et puis la notion de
quota très rigide qui qui qui est très
compliqué à mettre en place d'ailleurs
tous les pays qui ont des des quotas ne
respecte pas leur quotas donc inutile de
de se cacher derrière ces mots faisons
des choses efficaces sur la
régularisation dans les métier en
tenstion puisque ça faisait partie des
points de débat le Sénat avait réécrit
ce fameux article 3 euh avec une
procédure pour simplifier qui était à la
main du préfet les députés ont remodifié
cet article pour rencadrer le pouvoir du
préfet mais sans pour autant revenir à
la version initiale du gouvernement
est-ce que le compromis vous convient ça
n'est absolument pas un compromis ça
n'est absolument pas un compromis c'est
le retour de l'article 3 en faisant
semblant de ne pas revenir à l'article
toi il faut revenir au principe enfin la
politique c'est pas la fin justifier les
moyens autrement on regarde comment les
choses se passent et on l'entérine la
politique ce sont des principes on on
évidemment on prend en compte le réel
c'est même le but de la politique mais
on le prend en compte avec des principes
le premier principe je le disais une
politique migratoire et ça personne ne
peut dire l'inverse une politique
migratoire c'est de dire en parlant des
étrangers qui rentre qui reste et à
quelles conditions le deuxième principe
qui en découle c'est que ceux qui ne
respectent pas les conditions doivent
partir et le trisè élément mais qui
vient ensuite c'est qu'à titre
exceptionnel ceux qui ne respectent pas
les conditions peuvent si l'État en
décide ainsi notamment par le la
décision du préfet c'est le cas
aujourd'hui dans l'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour la fameuse
circulaire Vals les non
le CZ le code de de séjour des étrangers
prévoit l'admission exceptionnelle au
séjour dans plusieurs cas où
effectivement comme c'est une admission
exceptionnel on présuppose que ceux qui
sont en France ne respectent pas les
conditions donc il faut impérativement
que les choses se fassent dans ce
sens-là car si vous prenez un principe
premier de politique migratoire qui dit
qui rentre qui reste à quelle conditions
et qu'ensuite vous dites mais quand vous
respectez pas les conditions vous avez
quand même le même droit que ceux qui
respectent les conditions vous anlez le
principe de la politique migratoire ce
qu' a créé l'Assemblée nationale euh le
gouvernement tout d'abord et ensuite
l'Assemblée nationale c'est ce qu'on
appelle un droit opposable au séjour
c'est-à-dire que l'État n'a plus
grand-chose à décider l'État n'a plus
grand-chose à décider si vous justifiez
que vous avez fraudé suffisamment
longtemps et suffisamment habilement
vous aurez le même droit que ceux qui
sont rentrés légalement donc c'est en
fait l'annihilation totale l'anniilation
totale d'une politique migratoire donc
moi je veux bien qu'on dise ah il faut
regarder les choses avec un peu de
pragmatisme le pragmatisme ça n'est pas
de pas passer le la politique migratoire
des main de l'État aux mains des
passeurs parce que c'est ça qui va se
passer mais non mais enfin c'est pas du
tout ça et en plus vous vous faites vous
faites à mon avis une erreur mettre ça à
la main du préfet c'est voilà on le sait
suivant les départements ce n'est pas la
même chose alors que justement nous
sommes la représentation nationale et
nous devons fixer ces règles et il y a
quelque chose de très contradictoire à
avoir envie d'une politique migratoire
et d'un autre côté de la mettre aux
mains du préfet c'est à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat de décider d'un
certain nombre de règles et de de
décider des règles qui permettent de
régulariser avec des exemption quand il
y a trouble à l'ordre publi quand il y a
un certain nombre de choses et la
plupart des gens qui sont rentrés dans
notre pays qui sont aujourd'hui en
situation illégale non pas fraudé ils se
sont retrouvés dans une situation
illégale suite à une erreur de papier
une erreur administrative donc il y a
quand même quelque chose qui est
paradoxal et puis vous le savez très
bien et et c'est et sur ce sujet je je
je ne comprends même pas vous qui
habitez le même territoire que moi qui
voyez les mêmes personnes que moi qui
voyez les mêmes entrepreneurs que moi
qui nous disent mais sur un tas de de de
postes on a des gens ils sont là ils ont
pas leurs papiers mais on les embauche
et il ils répondent parfaitement à ce
qu'on veut et ils ont envie de
s'intégrer et ré régulariser s'il vous
plaît ces personnes on l'a tous les
jours dans nos permanences et et dans
nos sur nos mails donc ne sortons de
cette hypocrisie de penser que des gens
sont là trichent et et ne ne participent
à rien et profitent du système je crois
que on a beaucoup de personnes qui sont
arrivées sur notre territoire parfois
parce qu'ils étaient étudiants parfois
par un visa de travail un premier visa
de travail et qui ont envie de rester
dans notre pays ont envie de s'intégrer
et il y a dans ce texte aussi et parce
que c'est des sujets auquels je je je
tiens tout un tas de de de dispositifs
sur l'intégration la le meilleur
apprentissage du français et et tout ça
me semble aller dans le bon sens et et
être plutôt justement très cohérent et
qui là ont été conservé hein par par le
Sénat sur l'apprentissage pour sur
qu'est-ce que vous dites ce que des
arguments der ran banant sur cet article
3 sur les bras on tomb un peu je dois
dire penseer que enfin c'est d'ailleurs
le propos du début et de la fin ne sont
pas les mêmes enfin dire qu' il est
normal de régulariser des gens qui sont
entrés à la faveur d'un autre titre de
séjour et se sont maintenus en situation
régulière sur le territoire m' paraît
totalement surréaliste encore une fois
c'est la nogation de la Pol migratoire
quand on dit qu'effectivement les gens
on pu rentrer à faveur d'un visa
étudiant ou d'un visa de travail qu'ils
veulent rester mais ce n'est pas aux
étrangers de décider s'ils veulent
rester en France c'est à l'état de le
dire à cet éard et à cet égard pardon
j'aimerais parler jusqu'au bout et à cet
égard que le
préfet soit doté enfin de d' pouvoir
d'admettre exceptionnellement au séjour
m'a paraît tout à fait normal enfin
c'est une politique régalienne tout de
même c'est une politique régalienne que
l'immigration que l'État à un moment
dise qui a le droit de rester et qui ne
vaa pas le droit de rester y compris en
admission exceptionnelle au séjour c'est
tout à fait normal que les décisions ne
soient pas les mêmes d'un préfet un
autre c'est tout à fait normal c'est une
admission exceptionnel c'est-à-dire que
on va examiner la situation au cas par
cas de personnes qui demandent donc
qu'il y ait une casuistique c'est tout à
fait normal c'est inhérent me
semble-t-il à la à la situation pour le
reste et bien enfin les les dizaines de
milliers de cutes qui sont délivrés tous
les ans ne le sont pas à des gens qui
sont victimes d'une erreur
administrative quant à ceux qui
travaillent et qui sont en situation qui
sont des étrangers il y a des étrangers
en situation irrégulière régulière je ne
suis pas contre une Imation une
immigration régulière de travail donc on
le voit cet article 3 qui a été
transformé en article 4 bis c'est la clé
de voûe de ce projet de loi immigration
et là il y a y a y a un désaccord qui
est qui fait que le compromis est
impossible entre les deux chambres du
Parlement vous vous en faites la
démonstration sur ce plateau je je suis
pas du tout je pense pas initialement
qu'est-ce qu'avait dit Monsieur
reetaillot qu'est-ce qu'avait dit la
droite en montrant ses gros c'est gros
brasos non pas de régularisation de
toute façon un droit opposable pas de
régularisation un droit opposable à
partir du moment où un dispositif faant
un texte de loi par définition il est
opposable donc arrêtons avec ce mot
opposable ou pas opposable c'est c'est
c'est notre règle c'est-à-dire que quand
il y a quelque chose que qui a été
inscrit dans la dans la loi on peut
l'opposer par voilà c'est c'est c'est
assez logique donc on avait un premier
temps pas de régularisation pas pas de
régularisation pas de régularisation on
voit bien parce que les sénateurs du
Sénat enfin les sénateurs républicains
côtoi les gens sur les territoires aussi
on voit bien qu'il y a un besoin il y a
un besoin économique et il y a un besoin
de répondre à des situations de
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui injuste
et on le sait bien les mêmes qui parfois
montent les gros bras sont ceux qui font
des dossiers avec le préfet ou appelle
le ministre de l'Intérieur pour
régulariser une situation donc arrêtons
l'hypocrisie avec le préfet oui mais le
préfet le préfet aujourd aujourd'hui le
préfet aujourd'hui gardera la
possibilité de dire non quand il y a des
situations c'est pas un droit de veto
c'est plutôt un droit d'appréciation et
de dire attendez là j'ai des éléments
objectifs qui me disent que ce n'est pas
juste et ce n'est pas enfin qu'il y a un
trouble à l'ordre publ il y a quelque
chose qui qui fonctionne pas mais que
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat les
parlementairire décide des critères
permettant cette régularisation ça
semble être le minimum pour un état de
droit alors oui effectivement reprocher
aux parlementaires qui montrent leur
gros bras de droite de de vouloir faire
admettre exceptionnellement le séjour un
certain nombre de personnes ça n'a aucun
sens personne n'a nié la nécessité d'une
admission exceptionnelle au séjour parce
que c'est vrai que parfois les textes la
procédure est sèche elle manque un peu
d'humanité elle manque un peu de bon
sens et tout le monde effectivement en
tout le monde beaucoup de parlementaires
font des demandes d'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour mais et ça ça
existe déjà et c'est sensiblement
différent du droit opposable je suis
navré mais ne pas voir la différence
entre les deux m'inquiète un peu là le
préfet n'a rien à dire si ce n'est pour
des motifs qui sont déjà dans le code de
séjour on a rien inventé dans cet
article 3 puisque l'ordre République la
polygamie sont déjà des cas dans
lesquels on ne délivre pas de on les
valeurs de la les principes de la
République le respect des principes de
la République mais on a très largement
repris le droit existant et c'est tout
de même le clandestin qui décide de
faire d'obtenir ce titre et on ne peut
pas s'y opposer autrement que pour çael
qui existe déjà pour le fait qu'on
puisse faire appel à des personnes enfin
je rappelle quand même qu'on a des
millions de chômeurs en France je
rappelle qu'on a inscrit à Pôle emploi
avec une autorisation de travail plus de
500000 étrangers plus de 500000
étrangers dont le taux de chômage est de
plus de 15 % donc si on a vraiment
besoin de manœuvre étrangère elle existe
déjà et elle n'est pas elle n'est pas
enfin elle n'a pas besoin de venir
fruduleusement en France
monirulusement on a compris qu' un
accord serait difficile peut-être un mot
sur un autre point quand même qui était
là aussi un point important c'est la
transformation de l'aide médicale d'État
en aide médicale d'urgence là aussi vous
êtes revenu dessus à l'Assemblée
nationale pourquoi l'aide médicale
d'urgence ça vous convenait pas parce
que on ne fait pas de santé en gérant
l'urgence la santé c'est de la
prévention c'est du travail
d'accompagnement c'est du long terme et
quand on est dans l'urgence c'est trop
tard et ça coûte beaucoup plus cher on a
auditionné un certain nombre d'acteurs
de la santé du directeur d'hôpital à
l'aide soignante tous nous ont dit et
surtout dans les zones euh un peu
compliqué genre s s par exemple euh tous
nous ont dit mais si vous faites ça aide
médicale d'urgence ils étaient on était
même pas au niveau supprime on supprime
tout vous allez causer des troubles dans
les hôpitaux un coup faramineux et un
problème de santé publique pour tout le
monde pour tous nos concitoyens donc
gardons l'aide médicale d'État on en
fait un fantasme certains en font un
bâton rouge je peux vous assurer que ça
fait faire des économies à la santé en
France
alors moi j'aimerais quand on discute de
ce sujet qu'on lise le texte qui est
sorti du Sénat parce que je n'entends
que des choses aberrantes je reconnais
une erreur c'est d'avoir app aide
médicale d'urgence une aide médicale qui
n'est pas que d'urgence puisque ça fait
partie du panel mais ce qui est écrit et
le mieux quand même quand on discute
d'un texte c'est de l'avoir lu mais je
croisavoir lu madame jour je vous ai pas
fait ce genre de reproche pense que
honnêtement quand on lit le texte on
voit bien que ça n'est pas une aide
médicale d'urgence alors la prophylaxie
mais enfin au-delà je reconnais l'erreur
du terme
mais la médecine préventive les vaccins
obligatoires les soins d'urgence les
maladies graves et les grossesses on a
un panel de soins qui est relativement
important qui effectivement garantit la
santé à la fois pour les personnes qui
sont là et à la fois pour des questions
de santé publique maintenant enfin
soyons très clair on parle d'économie on
parle de moi je n'ai jamais fondé cette
ce ce principe d'aide médicale d'État
transformé dans aide médicale d'urgence
sur une question d'économie enfin car
c'est assez difficile à dire en l'état
même si si on peut voir dans dans le
rapport notamment le rapport de Ligas
qui avait été fait en 2019 qu'il y a un
certain nombre de soins qui sont
surreprésentés chez les les clandestin
qui bénéficie de laame par rapport au
reste des des bénéficiaires ce qui
d'ailleurs vous dire à l'époque
l'inspection générale des finances et à
l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales qu'il
venait probablement pour obtenir ce type
de soin mais la vraie la vraie question
c'est qu'aujourd'hui et on ne peut pas
ne pas l'entendre il y a des Français
qui eux travaillent ctisent et qui se se
rendre compte que sont mieux pris en
charge que à certains égards même si
parfois les carart des sommes est
minimes sont mieux pris en charge que
des gens qui sont en situation
irrégulière sur le territoire et qui ne
cotisent pas c'est une question de
cohésion sociale l'aide médicale
d'urgence ben moi moi c'est vous vous
j'aime bien cet aveu madame Jourda vous
avez voulu faire de la vous non mais
vous allez vous avez vous avez voulu
faire de la politique et vous avez voulu
stigmatiser les les un certain nombre de
de personnes et et et un et un
dispositif en en le critiquant mais en
réalité en voyant bien qu'il est
efficace et qu'il fonctionne et en en
changeant le nom vous vous êtes vraiment
pris les pieds dans le tapis pour le
coup bon voilà en réalité c'est bien la
preuve que quand on fait des des ce
qu'on est sur les sujets de politique
migratoire moi je le dis toujours il
faut mettre le plus loin possible les
idéologies et essayer de travailler dans
l'efficacité le pragmatisme et le
respect de nos valeurs républicaine un
mot sur le rapport Evin Stéphan qui a
été rendu hier là-dessus oui il semble
donner raison à la majorité présid
identi il parle de laame comme d'un
dispositif sanitaire utile globalement
maîtrisé je cite le rapport qui ne
génère pas de consommation de soins
faisant apparaître des atypismes abus ou
fraude structurel fin de citation
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à cet
argument stéphaninianini qui un homme de
droite encien directeur de la campagne
de Françis Fillon mais oui c'est assez
perturbant parce que le rapport
stéphanini de de décembre 2023 n'est pas
le livre Stéphan de novembre 2020 où
alors pour le coup il était beaucoup
plus dur que ce qu'on a fait puisque
voilà j'ai rappelé qu'elle était le
panier de soins assez complet que le
Sénat a prévu pour les clandestins euh
pour le coup monsieur stéphanini il
était pour qu'on ait les soins urgents
et les maladies contagieuses donc quelle
est la raison de ce changement de pied
je ne la connais pas je ne la vois pas
et je n'ai pas observé que les
conditions changé depuis 202 qui dit que
la mu c'est dangereux je oui alors
encore une fois il disait il disait
exactement l'inverse il y a 3 ans donc
c'est un peu compliqué ce que dit le
rapport ce que dit le rapport c'est que
alors la question c'était quoi c'était
de savoir si effectivement ça crée un
appel d'air un appel encore une fois je
le dis notre position c'est pas un aveu
que j'en fais aujourd'hui je l'ai
toujours tenu en hémicycle et je l'ai
toujours dit notre position elle était
pas motivée spécialement par ça il n'en
reste pas moins que ce que dit le
rapport et que laame fait partie des
avantages qui peuvent conduire à venir
en France et qui probablement peuvent
conduire à rester clandestin donc le
rapport n'est pas il faut le dire il n'a
pas enfin je ne doute pas que lu
d'ailleurs der après j'ai une dernière
question peut-être que Monsieur
stéphanini là a travaillé avec tout les
éléments c'est beaucoup plus simple de
faire un rapport Parlement un rapport
gouvernemental où on a accès à tous les
chiffres et peut-être que Monsieur
stéphanini s'est rendu compte de son
erreur après moi je moi je vois dans le
rapport il dit qu'il faut aller plus
loin en réalité le rapport hein il dit
qu'il faut éviter les ruptures de soins
il faut la transition entre le le la
personne qui est irrégulière et qui
devien régulière c'est un vrai sujet
parce que là-dessus on est moi je suis
assez d'accord il faut qu'on revoit
enfin voilà c'est un beau travail de de
d'analyse qui nous permett d'avoir un
bin un dernier mot de conclusion est-ce
que un accord vous sent possible sur ce
texte est-ce que la majorité
présidentielle tend encore la main au LR
et espère le vote des LR ran balanon bah
depuis le début de de cette mandature on
a fait on a trouvé beaucoup d'accord et
donc je je pense que peut-être sou sur
la ligne de du Sénat de droite ou oui
c'est non je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord sur sur certains textes on a su
imposer voilà j'étais j'étais j'étais
dans la commission mixte paritaire du
texte strrain par exemple je pense que
on a fait un bon travail avec les les
sénateurs et on a réussi à aboutir bon
est-ce qu'on aboutira c'est pas un drame
si on aboutit pas moi je le dis c'est
aussi le travail parlementaire on
l'oublie c'est des navettes hein avec un
dernier mot c'est le mot à l'Assemblée
nationale juste c'est pas un drame c'est
pas grave s'il y a pas de texte ou c'est
pas un drame vous passerez pas 49 vous
êtes s de votre majorité à l'Assemblée
na pour l'instant je suis je 34 pour 16
contre en en en machin il y a une vraie
Monopol voilà ENF Muriel Jourda est-ce
que vous êtes prês des compromis en
commission mixte paréire B écoutez il ne
faut pas qu'on a un texte trop éloigné
du autre encore une fois on peut avoir
un texte qui a une cohérence maintenant
si effectivement enfin les lignes rouges
c'est très simple sur ce plateau même je
les avais énoncé c'était l'article 3
c'est-à-dire le la la régularisation de
droit et l'ame transformable en Amu en
quelque chose qui s'appelle autrement
mais qui conforme à ce que dit le Sénat
donc je pense que en l'état mais je F
obserz quand même qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale le débat n'a pas encore eu
lieu donc il est difficile de savoir si
nous allons avoir une CNP sur un texte
qui n'existe pas
on vous réinvitera une fois que le taex
est sorti de séance alors on referait le
débat on referait le débat après le taex
sorti de
séance